hey everybody
welcome to stream coco
yeah how's everybody doing uh we was
that a whistle yeah
it's the best i can do and still not
good enough uh welcome everyone uh beth
is out sick today um so uh sorry beth i
know you're probably watching at home
and if you're watching at home
turn this off feel better beth no don't
feel no feel better that's you don't
need to listen to him uh why don't you
introduce yourself for people who don't
know it's a thing
to show you i was doing a thing like
it's a whole
oh now i can't all right why don't you
introduce yourself
to people who don't know you my name's
rj hey everybody i work here with mr
aaron blake we don't work together we
work
hand in hand you might geographically
close we don't touch i'm more of a
silent partner to blake i'm just a
behind the scenes guy to belay
everything he does there's a curtain
right here and i'm always behind it
pulling the strings it's more of like uh
peeping tom hiding outside of my house
like yeah exactly
rj uh big zelda fan that's right he's a
huge zelda fan
so this is true the last console i ever
had was a nintendo 64 and it's still all
i play is that true yeah so saddest
story i've heard i'm not good at the
double
the double nipples or whatever these are
called they're called joysticks these
things they're they're joysticks you can
just call them joysticks because that's
what they're called i'm only good at one
uh somebody asked me to wear the same
pants on purpose
oh my oh my goodness goodness and kind
of this oh my god our shoes are the
opposite
look at that
there we go the answer is yes yeah we
did we planned it of course uh you know
you can you can play so this is the
switch this is the switch man okay it's
pretty cool it's like the will smith
song
switch
is there
yeah we don't have the money to play it
though um
yes so uh we're gonna play uh breath of
the wild or as i call it bad breath
breath of the wild
wild animals have bad breath i'm sorry
nintendo you named your game after an
animal's
animals just you know it is a weird name
breath of the wild that's what are you
doing that's a terrible oh this is it
it's okay this is it we're playing we're
playing okay so we're wearing pants and
we're wearing a shirt
uh we're dying we've got uh only three
quarters of heart left this is what
we're picking up where we left off
has the switch glitched out yet no there
hasn't been a switch glitch yet switch
glitch uh i am dying in the game otaku
shark guy
um
yes jungle gym mania good news to you as
well good noon all right let's let's
play here let's play hit these buttons
and hitting the buttons do it get out of
here oh no don't remove your shirt just
can you really do that yeah
first you can all right all right all
right all right
so uh what do i do what do i do back oh
all right there we go
so what we want to do is go towards a
lot of stuff on my back yeah you've um
oh you know what truck yeah i think we
just killed a bunch of dudes okay
so i think we want to do is go towards
at the moment i think we have to eat
something to feel better all right can i
eat this oh yes you can go up there and
eat that
cool now i've i've heard in this game
you can kind of do anything like climb
every tree oh yeah dudes
oh yeah you're going to want to eat that
seared steak sure oh yeah how do i eat
that didn't work
it didn't give me life how do i i think
it's in your i think it's in your
inventory hit plus
i'm so sorry there it is
it's okay
so you're going to want to hit a right
eat
jumbo there we go feeling way better all
right all right great there we go
all right
who's that wild animals really have bad
breath says skill luck i'm guessing so
they don't brush their teeth do that you
want to kill that thing
uh so you're going to want to hit why i
think uh
uses your club oh there's a club yeah so
and if you hit the left trigger it'll uh
like you know lock onto them there you
go can i use my bow and arrows oh
yeah you can really how do i do that
yeah you got to go into your inventory
and select uh the bone okay i'm gonna do
that
hey rj what are you most excited about
with this game says otaku shark guy well
my last favorite game ever was
ocarina of time oh i love that game this
seems like the most that's the only one
i've beat the only zelda game yeah i
tried to beat majora's mask back in the
day and that was way too confusing for
me i gave up
uh skillet does kona know you're playing
video games all clocked on yes actually
he does that's part of my job is playing
video games
um so quip yes
hello man f94 oh legion titan like zelda
me too uh how do i lock on again uh left
trigger you got it how do i shoot oh
keem die bot is out i'm out [ __ ]
oh
yeah what's your first game you ever
played me yeah first game ever played
get that chest yo get that chest get up
there get that chest go up there
get that chest um i do remember getting
a regular nintendo that was probably my
first
first thing and uh my first like game
that i was in love with was excite light
oh love excitement excite like yeah yeah
a little oil slick she had to go around
we got an opal
or as i call it an oh pal
uh tori says how was mexico mexico was
great a lot of fun in mexico did a lot
of great stuff you can see our mexico
episode at teamcoco.com mexico along
with a lot of other behind-the-scenes
stuff and even whole acts that didn't
make the show with uh chef aquile
chavez who's the host of topshop mexico
and um a great stand up sophia i'm not
going to know her name i want to say
rivera
fantastic someone's glistening almost
done with this game says juicy player
how juicy player what do we have to look
forward to you can help us you can be
our shaman guide
[Music]
patrick uh beating all the legends of
zelda games love this it's pretty great
how's it all hey bearsky what's up
out of 10
ej kryptonite uh i mean i haven't gotten
into this game enough to really rate it
but i'll give it a 10.
i'd like to
i will i start
up high and then i take away points i'm
climbing this rock face
yeah you are
now careful you only have x amount of
stamina
so when you run out you'll fall down i'm
going to try to get above this thing
my job is getting abused by conan that's
true hey from uk hey graham what's up
viral patel played it
um oh maria so you guys play all day
while conan does all the work correct
yes and gets paid millions to do it so
um
can i fly how old am i says ivan i'm
almost i'm almost done i'm almost dead
so we're close reaching the end right at
the end i'd say i got about another 10
months left and that's it yeah
uh question
uh oh otaku saw the mexico episode and
loved it uh yes what's your question
that i can't answer oh look it's there's
so much love from a
uh no we don't have the glider yet that
we have to do what we're trying to do is
where those things are on the map we're
trying to go there beat all of those
then we get the glider to go to the next
section
so head towards one of those things
above all right so keep going bro
gearing up to face ganon in the final
fight in your game oh man awesome
when is zelda getting her own game great
question
oh there was warm coat
oh tiger what was zelda's game
hello from curacao oh my god hey grange
are you trying to save zelda in this
game
i don't know like in ocarina of time you
don't know i'm guessing have you played
this game i have not very well oh god
i'm gonna run out of stamina how do i
get more stamina
right ej kryptonite it is going on the
youtube channel too
does anybody love cats hillbilly
poindexter i love cats i have two i
don't know
how do i get more stamina i mean you
have to
stand
do i have stamina in here no
herbs no
just some weight
i don't it's not gonna help you if i go
down oh no you're totally screwed all
right
why are you going sideways
yes
wow
lucky yeah
bad on the knees i'm gonna jump on this
what is this mr kitty cat games it's the
legend of zelda
breath of the wild breath of the wild
hi from germany hey
that's cool
what time is it in germany right now
have a clueless gamer for this game or
at least do the more often we're working
on it we're working on it
andy valma the gray guy please shot your
head with the gun and never come back
um
why the head why has it got to be the
head
i can just shoot myself in the gut it's
a much more painful death yeah gut shots
i saw i watched tombstone again last
night because that's one of the greatest
uh movies ever i've never seen it i've
never seen a great movie
and this is how cool life can be i'm
walking to actually get coffee larger
this morning and who do i see eating
some greek yogurt with his friends sam
elliott that's so cool that's right
did you see by the way um jeff bridges i
knew that yeah i pulled out the dude's
uh sweater and did a little bit of the
dude for john goodman when he got a walk
on the hollywood star finn it's pretty
cool pretty great
although i wish he had john goodman the
whole time just looked very confused
no he got it no immediately when he
pulled out the sword he goes dude
um but i really wish jeff bridges would
have said you know uh yeah this star
really ties the whole walk together man
yeah you know yeah man
uh
exactly so these things give you life
eat them up dude
all right good good good good
quad lock don't go to work call in sick
yeah versky that's right call in sick
baby hello from the white house is coco
egg i think you're lying but yeah
that'd be weird um
yeah i love conan's pizza bill paxton
bill paxton the man i know matching
pants
yeah what new piece of hyrule technology
do we have punk
what's up rob revenge
who is that hyrule castle
or just some random church do you know
jordan schlansky
what are you drinking there remember the
beard uh i'm drinking seltzer a little
refreshy
look at this uh that's a good just right
from rj's face
all right
pro tip grab a cuckoo and let enemies
hit it it's a cuckoo
cool
i'll cook the food you'll get more
health that way thank you freaky maggie
why aren't you guys playing ghost recon
does conor not even play the good games
when he's not around uh i've played
ghost recon how is it i haven't played
it was it fun
i will say that this isn't the most
exciting game
to watch at this point
and i apologize that's true although i
think our banter is pretty exciting it
is the most exciting we have i think we
have pretty snappy witty banter i'm
happy i've got more your shirt with
parrots on it hey you want to hear a
joke we're like the two guys in the
muppets
yeah uh waldorf and uh statler waldorf
why don't you sing a solo
[Music]
try holding down the right trigger
nope
sorry
oh dead
dead
you got beefed
oh the temple of time not a random
church this gold's bro no
all right
oh were you going were you in a uh were
you in an area with low temperature are
you even like oh it was snowing yeah i
think you're dying your turn around
you'll die from the cold thank you gold
goldsboro
doesn't make a lot of sense i love how
aaron uh super talkative conan isn't
there to shut him down every time he
pipes up you know what i'll say this
there's a little book it's called the 48
laws of power now look here's the thing
oh yeah they give it to prisoners no
they don't give it to prisoners it's
just a it's it's a hot book in prison
yeah yeah and it's a i gotta say it it's
a if you want to be like a super villain
it's a great book it's amazing
the first one is the first rule it's
it's basically how to get and and how to
get and keep power i hate that you're
gonna follow the cliff you know what
don't worry about it
oh oh look oh how did you do that uh hit
b
ah jesus
um
ah miss me um did we play that racing
game you know what don't give up on this
anyway for your last part first law
first law never outshine the master law
number one never outside the master
don't make your boss look bad you know
my job is to make him look good and it's
an easy job because he's the man he
makes himself look good so you know when
he's around i just shut up i don't want
to be funny
i will say in that book there are some
crazy ones yeah one yeah yeah like uh
it's not a great book if you want to be
like a good person no no no no this is
if you want to like take over something
like the world
uh
it's
yeah it's like keep your enemies close
so you can pounce on them
one is free one is like make make good
you make uh make good use of your
enemies yeah uh and if you don't have
enemies make some yeah you're like oh my
gosh you need them you always need it
yeah but it's true it's like hire your
enemies because then they'll be
subservient to you and they'll work
harder because they're you know your
enemy it's it's a i gotta say it's a
really interesting book it's worth a
read carlos sanchez asks is the switch
worth it i think it is i think it's
great and in a little while there are a
lot of games there aren't that many
games but again like with any new system
you know yeah
um i'm gonna i'm heading towards the
purple thing by the way just so we all
know where i'm going okay
actually maybe you you were close to the
yellow one right and that's up i was
trying i don't know
um
later skater do you have a sword yet ow
i have a um i have like a club
you know i'm doing what the kid in game
of thrones should have done and running
in a zigzag pattern so i can't get
tagged
when alligators come at you is that true
kind of kept this finger
um
yeah 48 laws of power man great book
switch will be more worth it later this
year when games are out wait for the
holidays yeah but i have to say like i
i my big thing was i didn't think that
the little cause this basically
controller is made up of two little
controllers i didn't think it would be
that comfortable because i have giant
hands and it actually is really fun to
play it totally works i hear that the
switch is very cool hand held too it's
awesome handheld yeah the thing is like
i just don't play games i just don't
play mobile games
so i don't think it's it's not a great
thing for me but
this is a
i was it's beautiful this game is a huge
very detailed game oh wait i think i've
already been over here haven't it
but i've already beat this
all the starks are dead that's not true
madamaniac no it's not true anya stark's
not dead sansa starks not dead sansa
arya uh jon snow jon snow half stark
did we find out that he's not a stark
no he's there's something weird at the
end
no he is a stark he's half stark and
half um
because
it's
no no it's ned's sister so like ned
stark was his uncle
oh and ned's sister lyanna died yeah
so he's ned's nephew he's ned's half
nephew half nephew yeah
oh no just nephew i can't wait for them
you can't be no you all nephews are half
nephews why because oh cause otherwise
it'd be
it'd be
sisters
uh
where am i going i'm going towards the
purple thing oh but i can't get down
there
were you in jail when you read the 48
laws of power no have you ever been to
jail uh
no but i've been to a jail like not i
have been to a jail i have not been in
jail
i got a ticket for urination in public
when i was in college i did
uh it's right and this is going to date
me but this is right when where are you
mike's hard lemonade came out yeah
and i drank like probably 20 000 of them
i drank like like probably 30 lemonade
or something yeah and
uh yeah i think it's like a proven fact
if you drink a mike's hard lemonade
nine times out of ten you'll get a
urination in public
it was during a riot by the way oh my
god and they arrest you the one they
didn't they didn't arrest i did not get
arrested by the way i just got a ticket
because there's a riot going on and by
the way at the same time uh so the guys
like go home i'm like okay so i'm
walking home and i see a guy punch a
police horse
it was crazy holy [ __ ] it was like
blazing saddles and it was like eight
cops came out of the ground and just
like
i mean it was amazing it was truly
amazing the horse didn't it didn't hurt
the horse at all
but the dude was you know
it's michigan state man things were nuts
back in the state
wild
this place is cool it's like ruins
i know
i can't go to the uh i can't go to the
the
um purple one so i'm going to the red
one that's why i'm changing my thing
about
jump off the plateau you're wrong dude i
did that last time
i had a terrible headache you're right
robert
happa happalullah bored by game of
thrones all right fair enough yeah
patron boy seven sevens i gotta say i
don't go to the yellow and red i don't
watch
sounds like where my parents would go in
florida
attend a riot drinking lemonade badass
it is
the least badass thing you could do
literally
hi
guys
i drink lemonade hard all the time well
played titan heroes
i prefer to see mega man running around
aimlessly to link running around you
know it would be cool to get an open
world um
that would be cool to get a world mega
man game are there plans to take jordan
to italy is that i think i can get i
think it would be great there's
no plan it's gonna be awesome
which version of pokemon is this well
played punching a horse horses are much
stronger than toughly yeah exactly
zacharias it didn't end well for the guy
either especially when it's
a police horse
i think you'd be better off punching a
police motorcycle yeah okay there's that
we gotta get up there dude is that the
other thing yeah that thing right there
and then and then uh
even if i don't die then you play
sometimes natural sometimes he comes on
the stream yeah he has it in a while
he's been really busy but
oh it's a little lizard does it
everything open world mega man would be
a beast of the far east is that z is
that a happy zombie open world mega man
would be awesome we don't i love mega
man i was mega man for halloween three
years ago
whoa
oh man it's going to get cold up here
again
oh be careful
oh nice
oh yeah it is look there's snow up here
oh dang am i dying do you have a coat no
jacket
i'm dying i'm gonna kill a bear and you
can skin it
that'd be cool
but what if i go down this way
let's see there's grass over here
yeah maybe it'll be all right over here
it can't be cold if there's grass right
guys science
it can't be that cold if there's grass
you guys
this is crap you need a coat
maybe we can wear that frog skin
can i eat any of this stuff
yeah there's nothing here i think that's
here we go hyrule herb
can you eat the no you can't eat any
corn
right
yeah it says you can yeah i'm not gonna
eat it now let's see if it
oh see this is better see i'm not as
cold wait where's the thing
wasn't it right around here
oh is that it down there no that's a
fire and a bunch of dudes
where's the gun
oh wait that's one right there
where right there
it's that yellow one that's where we
want to go over there
how do i get down there
oh dude don't don't don't tell me how to
live you [ __ ]
my palms are always drenched in sweat
cat uh anika what is the main objective
of this game that's my that's my secret
cap i'm always sweaty i don't know
i don't know we're gonna go down here i
assume it's to save zelda or
help zelda
let's just party all the time her name
is in the party
are you sure that's it i think it's in
this thing i think it's close dude we've
been in there no it's right there i see
it it's that orange thing
you fool
oh my gosh in real life this would be so
hard
oh yeah didn't you break your ribs climb
into a mountain
yeah
tell us the story what happened i just
fell i fell while i was climbing wow
you're such a storyteller i know right
geez what a rockin tour hey tell us the
story of how you're climbing a mountain
and broke your ribs i just fell i just
fell bro
uh
yeah i slipped i went over like a little
let there was a ledge i thought i was
safe uh the momentum kind of carried me
under and i lost an anchor
and uh
i fell but the next anchor caught me and
i swung against the wall
whoa damn cracked my rib yeah so pretty
cool
it hurt it was it was like it was not
the word i was one of the worst days
it does not seem like the right word but
i will say it had to have been worse for
my buddy who's right next to me who just
saw me go whoop
and he was probably like oh
[ __ ] look at this guy like when i'm here
oh apples
this game should be called johnny
appleseed no it shouldn't that's why
would it be called johnny appleseed
appleseed one around planting zelda
apples nope
that's not
he didn't
no he went around planting apples that's
not what we're doing at all we haven't
planted a single apple we're taking
apples johnny apple eater no it's not
i guess well technically it could be
johnny apple eater
how do i get that apple can i shoot it
excited to see a snow plow for the first
time during the snow storm today i don't
know where you are
yuri
but i heard you're all supposed to get a
bunch of snow
on the east coast that's exciting is
that a meteorologist meteorological yeah
yeah today that's true a bunch of snow
lots of snow so much snow seriously like
two feet of snow on the east coast dc
new york boston
all those places
can we get a green screen back here so i
can do a weather report oh i'm glad we
didn't they wanted to bring one in and i
specifically said no for that reason
that's a [ __ ] because i don't want to
see you do another weather report
another weather report
all right now you know [ __ ] this apple i
don't care
all right
it's somewhere over this way man
wasn't it around here somewhere am i
making that up it was just right over
here
oh yeah let's go down again
joan mar we haven't licked any game
cartridges here's the deal
rj yeah the deal is what is what's the
deal with the licking game card the deal
is this is what we found out last time
so ninten so the game cartridges for the
switch are very small they're like
little
uh uh flash you know what i'm saying
like oh okay okay and so nintendo didn't
want kids eating them
so they made them very bitter
no
so if you lick them it's supposed to be
gross and i don't think we have any i
want to try one yeah i don't think we
have any hey there's our friend over
there
how come you don't have uh navi or
whatever navi yeah remember from all
that's avatar dude no no no no from all
the old zelda games you'd have like a
little fairy to tell you hey listen it's
this guy this is our navi oh really
santa
[Music]
you've ever planned on getting some
revenge on conan for all those punches
yes i've been slowly poisoning him for
like six years with these cartridges
with these cartridges i've been slipping
these cartridges in their food yeah gabe
that's right
do what sp candidates uh there's no lick
the cart
coney's passed out junk behind the couch
connor says like please use the map when
you're running around
oh okay fair enough
all right well
where's the map where's my map back
lad you don't know anything about zelda
do you listen it's been a long time like
i was in eighth grade when i was playing
this game
i thought it's like this way man i don't
know the name of the fairy
wasn't it navi or something like that
navi
is this the n64 version okay
well that's what i'm familiar with
where the
f was that stupid thing what did that
guy tell you i wasn't paying attention
he was just like using axe to chop down
trees it was dumb
what are the health benefits of nintendo
switch cartridges that's a great
question good question no idea which
vitamins
need to get conan to lick the cartridge
all right we'll buy a cartridge and have
fun
it was down here man i saw it
jimmy kudo who even watches this
i don't know
you apparently all right here you wanna
go kill this thing yeah
let's save the game real quick
save
then maybe we race is that a thing
sure
we can
oh wow all right here you go
what happened
uh oh hit uh
no no yeah yeah
get him dude get him left trigger left
trigger homes in on him
my god you're bad at doing this
[Music]
dude oh god
chase of the
why am i ducking duck duck and and just
walk very slowly
what's happening hold on hold on i need
a weapon
there you go
a club tell me more about this book
chapter by chapter control picks uh what
else the 40 laws of power okay there's
never outshine the master well you know
what i'm gonna look him up look him up
because guys this is this stream's gonna
be this this could correct this stream
is going to be all about how to become a
super become powerful become powerful
uh all right let's see for you also like
zuckerberg and stuff read this book why
because dude
not you i'm trying to figure out how to
all right hold on
and again we're not recommending you do
this stuff because it's pretty gnarly
no
no
okay i'm just so
uh
what are the god
the other thing about the 48 laws of
power is this
it's kind of cool because every chapter
basically
it explains what the law is
then explains a little bit of history i
just said deja vu i just said deja vu
foreign
then it explains a little bit of history
about like you know in uh in ancient
times in the ming dynasty there was this
guy who didn't do this thing and then
whatever and then it says uh
and then it's kind of like uh the
transgression of the law then it's like
a person fatherland did well and then
it's like the exceptions to the law so
it's like never not shine the master you
should outshine the master if like your
emperor is like on his way out then you
should outshine it because then you'll
if everyone hates them everyone hates
the master but
then it's like if they're on their way
out
in and they're really on their way out
don't outshine them because then it'll
just like look like you're beating up on
them right which is bad yeah so it's
like an interesting it's it's cool it's
weird how did we get to the loading
screen i died and then dude clicks well
hit continue no i want to i thought we
were racing oh you wanna well hold on
one second yeah can i just read the laws
of power you guys want to see the laws
of power real quick
uh
you died no one case take the stone from
my hand nobody cares all right fine
let's just play uh nobody cares about
the laws of power all right i'm trying
to make everybody powerful but it's not
gonna work well i was i can read them
all right well there's a lot of naked
photos on my phone all right
uh okay here we go
laws of power
we're gonna play fast fmx
hit me with those laws says default
gekko looking for him looking
they're not on their wikipedia page so i
know i just wait hold on we have to take
we're taking these out so you do check
this out
oh yeah what yeah doc wait wait get
ready your phone
wait i have to use this yeah dog how do
you do this you press these two buttons
up top
these two yeah
well this is awesome impressive dog
at the same time yeah
oh wait
all right let's go
[Music]
all
[Music]
there you go now move around i'm trying
oh what'd you do i just oh sorry that's
all right oh sorry i chose the thing for
you sorry sorry
boo
yeah it kind of is like arrow gage yeah
kiss him we've already kissed beastie
boy
look at that whale all right so here's
the thing man hitting the top button
changes the color of your booster and
you want the same color booster as
you're going over does that matter i
mean does that you understand so hit
this button
to go right
and then hitting the top button changes
the color of your booster
does that make sense
the top no it doesn't really
oh this reminds me of an n64 game that
you can't remember the name of
you're thinking of uh
f-zero yeah
were you like yeah you're like in these
little tubes
tunnels you want to
i think i'm beating
are you i don't understand the
uh the color thing you just talked about
oh come on
yellow's bad apparently no no no it's
not bad if you hit the top of the
buttons you hit this button it changes
the color of your thing
[Music]
oh and then you eat oh i blew up
and then you aim for that color yes
are you making you know the game is
making noises you don't also have to
make noises with your mouth
the game has those built in it's a new
thing it's a switch
yeah yeah it makes its own noises
oh you know what else this reminds me of
did you ever play the like the boat
racing game usually it was in an arcade
of some kind no
racing game uh yes i love boats and i
love racing i think i would love that
game
[Music]
oh
guys
i'm great at this game let's be honest
i'm beating you
barely
that's true it is barely
[Music]
oh man you're right on my ass
oh what the hell was that you had a box
rookie mistake says the guy who just did
it
also
this game's fun it's awesome
oh yeah blue yellow
[Music]
oh dude i'm so super charged right now
it's ridic
it's ridix
oh he's gonna pass him nope
ah get out of here rubbing his racing
baby
oh here we go
oh
god
at the same time
oh dude which way are you gonna go which
way you go yellow oh
oh you got it yes you saw me yes
no
ah damn oh yeah baby nice job that was a
good race that was fun
it's a good game
[Music]
looks cool it's no mario kart though
it's no few things are
few things are
i took a capture for some reason
uh kamigori somebody's got another uh
power law of power number 13 when asking
for help
apply to people's self-interest yes
exactly never their mercy or gratitude
that's true
all the loss of power man i'm telling
you
here we go welcome to the kenshi jungle
[ __ ] all right who's putting money on
this race
hopefully no one oh there's other people
right brittany [ __ ]
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
the kenshu jungle
a terrible place to live the worst place
to die
oh i got some major boosties off of that
major boost i call it i call it major
boosies
oh you dick are you are you oh jesus
christ
are you doing a lot of drifting yeah
yeah i gotta drift more man drifter dude
that's my problem
how do you know what place you're in oh
on the bottom
what are you doing i'm in i'm way at the
end dude i'm i'm not good at this game
and i'm also terrible driving in real
life so
good to know anyone out there if you
ever ask me for a ride know that you're
taking your own life in your hands
oh first place baby oh my god oh and i
crashed oh little hubris there yeah
these things crash really easily yeah
they do they're not well designed cars
would you ever own a tesla oh heck yeah
really yeah it's gonna be the
environment dude
by the way there's like weird barriers
in there this is getting very hungry
hard
totally hit the thing
are you ninth no you're sick how am i
still ten yeah jesus
fifth i'm
walking back up the ranks here what's
your strategy why are you so good at
this game i don't know i think i'm a
good driver that's not true i've driven
here definitely
uh you have to have a little bit of like
not to get too nerdy on you or anything
you have to have a higher medical orient
count you know what i mean it's like
padres
oh
damn it you gotta be able to sense
what's coming a high meta what are you
talking you know you're saying you're
part jedi like anakin
like anik oh you mean like the worst
the worst uh darth vader yeah they're
the worst villain in all of well just
going with the laws of power theme yeah
exactly today's episode
and yeah today is me it's how to become
a super villain
guys but first
i'm hanging back and hey who else isn't
believing this dude you found your game
this is my jam
[Music]
wow i suck at this
[Music]
later sam's face
yeah we're okay what's going on
i have the high ground and again again
i love it
love it a snooky's jar jar probably
probably no smoke is uh snoke is um that
that other bad guy he's like evil yoda
evil i mean snoke is going to be tiny
right we all know he's got to be he's
got to be tiny
hit this thing right thank you
joan maher
which one
breath of the wild is great johnson we
took a little break from breath of the
wild i need more boosties you're right
[Music]
all right last one here we go
this is for all the cookies wow you're
already in third i'm intense all the
cookies
wow while i'm in the water
is that is it good do i want to be in
the water i think so i think the point
is to be in the
water oh my god this is horrible all the
cookies
all the cookies all the boosties here we
go
i see a blue coming up yeah
man i could play some mario kart
well is there another system so nope
i mean there probably will be i'm sure
there will be yeah this guy
this is nintendo right yeah
i'm in fourth we'll place you
oh it's still tenth baby hold down the
holding on the rear you like because i
like to hold down the rear you know what
i'm saying
i don't know what that
[Music]
oh yeah there we go oh [ __ ] stay on the
track man the first place guy is really
far ahead
i can see him barely
what i do is just slow down
to where i will be in front of the first
place guy you know what i'm saying
uh yeah
right before he's gonna lap you
oh jesus christ that was scary what just
happened
i do like the music dangerous polar
bears are there polar bears out here
music's dope yeah
[Music]
dead i'm just barely hanging on by a
thread and i'm 10.
mario kart 8 deluxe what is that whoa
what's mario kart 8 deluxe
very excited
[Music]
come on first place guy where are you
i'm eight
coming in hot
coming in hot
if you press in the left stick you can
do a boost
what
oh that's dope yeah
i you didn't know that you're still just
destroying me at this game
oh next month it's coming to the switch
damn
[Music]
that's got to be one of the greatest oh
yeah tag lines or taglines ever
second place i even use that boost at
the end
i think i need to use more of that
seven pretty good in this game you're
great at this game let's play something
else okay
the deluxe is for more shake mario kart
8 with new features all
right mario kart deluxe is mario kart
for switch interesting
[Music]
i do like pizza cloud dude i haven't had
it though in a long time but i like
pizza this guy wrote it wrote a pizza
script every friday
love pizza
this is better than zelda gold skulls
i kind of agree
now we're gonna play a game called
wait can you hit
what are we playing
snipperclips
is that real
yeah [ __ ] snipperclips [ __ ] reels it
gets is it two player yeah it's two
player
do you want to change the thing to snip
oh god it's riley
snipperclips hey salem dimes i love you
too conan's treating me very well thank
you
um snipperclips cheat yourself blade
it's okay i can't i can't guys i'm sorry
until i get a girlfriend no pizza
and then eat it then i gained 85 pounds
you know like i lost 85 or i lost 90
pounds
90. and then uh you had to beat me
that's right and then what is the point
of this game can you explain this we are
going to work together i know it's gonna
be hard for you to try to beat different
challenges
all right
okay it's called snipperclips [ __ ] all
right
get used to it we're two little paper
things we snip each other's clippers
don't you take that out of context
look i'm pink
here's the thing
here's the thing okay
look i can jump on you oh snipperclips
snipperclips snipperclips all right here
and look these the top buttons the top
buttons do this rotate you right
so if i come over there
yep now you're this how did you do that
it's updated
oh it's updated thank you
oh i didn't see o'malley back there how
did you snip it i just by pressing uh
this button and then if you hold this
button
oh sorry if you hold this button the
left button here
get yourself back yeah
all right so now we gotta figure out how
to get the bowling ball into the thing
all right oh don't let it fall on you oh
all right here pass it [ __ ] heavy bro
pass it over i can't it's too heavy wait
come over here i gotta sniper your
clipper look look
go
uh
no i need to make a little thing out of
here i need to make your head and do a
canoe
sorry i got it i got it i got it no dude
come back i can get this i'm an idiot
here it goes put over here put it on me
all right
here oh stop being an oh my god
dude it's teamwork would you listen to
me
look put it in my thing i'm trying to
put it in your thing
oh cause there's a little part that's
messed up
here look stop it let it go let it go
you're being a fool
come over here and i'll make it hit your
head into a canoe come here all right
look sideways here like this
there we go okay
oops sorry i'll keep going
all right all right
goofy game hold on i'm gonna make a
little snipper out of your clipper
there we go
oh my god why didn't i giggle when you
did it using tickles probably
all right we gotta get okay here we go
let's get a new one why
there you go all right
careful no wait i'm gonna do this and
you jump on top of me
can you jump
oh you can't ah here you know what take
some wait take some
take some what i'm just gonna say here
get on me here oh sorry that's a good
idea that's a good idea that's a good
idea
worst person i know terrible teammate
the most
egregiously self-hating game ever that's
true would you get on top of me i
thought that would work
ah
look hold on
he didn't get low enough
i'm low all right ready
here we go here we go trying to put it
in your thing okay here we go go go ah
don't you don't move i'll move when
you're on top of me i'll move
here we go let it go this game ruined
literally the game that ruins
relationships is where we go there we go
ready come on wait wait wait get up i'm
easy crying you always just moved over
okay here we go all right you moved me
this is weird whatever's happening right
now is weird look at the one eye look at
my yeah
[Music]
oh
oh
i slow my guy's just fine with it no no
get it in there ah
all right this is a good try wait i
gotta make your head into a canoe thing
again i'm sure are you sure yeah yeah
well yeah your head's flat
[Music]
all right sniffer that clipper here we
go
well [ __ ] that up again please
my god jesus dude would you chill the
[ __ ] out so sorry oh my god why is this
happening because when you press the
button one comes down so stop pressing
the button oh
it's a different story if you listen to
this stream with your eyes closed move
over oh sorry what games do i play on
ps4 and switch
uh switch i've only really played the
three we've played today all right ready
yeah
i don't like my face here by the way it
looks so perverted all right hold on
should i
all right i think you want to kind of ju
i'm going to go higher can you
jump it up
god
damn it you suck at this my god oh
all right i got it i got it i got it
here we go here we go here we go
here we go
can i tilt
more
wait i'm going to tilt i'm going to tilt
it over and then i'll jump all right oh
i can't jump
oh god that's the size i can get okay
wait we're gonna jump at the same time
alright ready ready one wait are we
jumping on three or one two three jump
on three so one two jump yeah one two
jump
yay
nice
god i hate this game
all right all right
this is the hardest game i've ever
played
all right
children's puddles i'm not buying the
zelda game where's the guy in the green
hat what green hat who play you made it
scoop backwards sorry this game is made
for alcohol correct aren't all games all
right what are we doing here all right
we gotta
is it all about getting a ball somewhere
and no some bird i was getting out all
right here can you make my head into a
point
sure
i don't know how but i'll try geometry
bro just uh snip
all right no wait i'm gonna turn the
other way oh wait come on the other side
of me
all right is that enough of a point i
think so i'm just gonna try to jump up
here and hit the thing all right
oh sweet what does this do
did you just do we need to write it
letter
oh my god no we gotta get it into the
pencil thing
this is so
look can you push it from that side
are you like humping you're literally
humping a pencil here you get oh yeah oh
yeah
you're definitely having sex with that
pencil
look at my face faces are horrible
you're just watching creepily
wait no
poop it up again
shoot it up yeah there we go there we go
no i think you need to i think i need
more of a i got to be more of a uh
[Music]
i think i think i need try putting your
thing down so you can push it i put your
thing down all the way how do i do that
yeah that way i
think oh yeah put it on top of me maybe
i need to be more of a
oh
oh
wait wait here we go here we go here we
go
it's backwards though dude we can't
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is
this is the dumbest thing i've ever seen
oh my god can i play as my girlfriend if
you want to break up with me break up
i think we have to go the other way man
we gotta sharpen the pencil the other
way oh [ __ ] we
oh
get it up there get it yeah yep yep yep
yep yep
all right wait try i need a new pencil
wait you made here try can you cut a
little more cut me cut me again cut me a
little more i think like along the top
maybe make me more of a ramp
you know what i'm saying no
more of a ramp
this is christ
stop it no reboot god you're out of
control all right here we go ramp
all right so i'm going to cut down here
no try do what i do do what i'm doing
right
there you go yeah
try a little bit more there yeah yeah
there we go take a little more at the
bottom a little more yeah maybe can you
get rid of that one little piece yeah
yeah uh
that's fine yeah
all right thanks all right
there we go we need a new pencil
oh i gotta get my here i we have to get
our heads into a uh
can you cut my other side that'll be
more of a point
which side oh to making me thinner to
hit
[Music]
that's good
it's so weird oh [ __ ] i wasn't ready i'm
sorry i'm sorry i wasn't ready
hey adida thank you for watching us
we're watching yeah two weird shapes
playing with a pencil here we go
all right oh dude don't you got this bro
you got this bro
[Music]
see if you can
hey back up wait oh you know what i was
going to go on the other oh perfect
perfect now we want to be the other way
though i think this isn't gonna work i
can't get under it though
let's try to flip it around there we go
there we go there we go there we go
there we go yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
this looks like something in a cab i
don't know what that means sorry debbie
this game would start building conflicts
it would
it's not gonna help global conflicts
all right here we go
all right there we go there we go
oh [ __ ]
game of the nintendo switch right here
agreed jungle gymmania this game is dope
i'm like what is happening here
there you go i think the pink eraser is
about ready to be put out to pasture
here we go yep you got it dude you got
this you got this
i'm gonna come underneath and pop it up
wait i'm gonna try to
hold on wait i'm gonna try to pop it up
okay oh
oh yeah hey i'm so close
there we go yes all right yes
careful
all right oh you got it all right all
right let me just go go forward just
move forward
[Music]
yeah
now you hit it up
wait can you squat down
yeah
damn that was ridiculous why isn't beth
thought green jungle germania beth's
sick today
this is definitely started debbie this
is all sexual human into
kind of me so mad if you had to review
this game i agree
i agree oh dude we opened one up awesome
wait let's play this one
this is definitely an 18 plus game
agreed 100
uh what do we do here
uh i bet if you get those get something
the buzzer up there
oh hit hit one of the hit the eraser
wait do we have to get the fly up there
god damn dude
oh do we have to get the fly up there i
don't know hit that eraser though well i
can't i need to be you gotta sharpen me
i'll sharpen you
[Music]
all right you got it
oh what happened
oh you can get items
what is this i think it opens this door
maybe
are we just breaking all these things
should i just break all these things
sure
oh yeah and let the fly out baby
[Music]
get it i'm just humping this ball
here
you
get it up and i'll hit it over
there we go
all right now maybe this thing
can i have to fly hit the thing
get over there you dumb fly
this is like my apartment get over here
fly
god
come on fly here get over here and stand
on me oh here we go i got him
oh damn
can i stand on him
yeah
oh dude oh we let it we lit the bulb
find a clue never clips n squared
snipper clips is serious business people
joke but it is
uh yeah glitch
um
that's sick today
this is asp yes this is acid flashback
simulator the key is under sock what
does that mean
what do we do here
let's hit the thing oh oh sorry dude
oh wait oh that was you you did that too
here you can still press it though
oh we have to
clip this stuff
what
[Music]
i think when you hit the thing it resets
it we i think we got a clip
we have to clip all the stuff that's not
[Music]
you know what i'm saying
we're trying to
dude i'm giving you stripes bro
[Music]
there's got to be an easier way to do
this yeah reset your guy
how do you do that again
we've almost got it dude
just down here a little bit
i think we did too much i think we
clipped it too much
let's try resetting
oh my sorry
[Music]
gotta be so exacting
i'll take the corners off
i work very slow
but i'm consistent
nice job
dude you are snipping the clippers up
snipping clippers
[Music]
i'm doing my part
get off my back i'm doing my part
i like more rounded corners
oh my god you killed me you actually
snipped my clip
wait
all right you finish it up
i'm going to finish i'm going to finish
it off
oh i did not mean to do that you are the
worst partner i've ever worked with
i am so sorry
i was just having so much fun
having so much fun snipping the clippers
how do we get this side oh you know what
oops you dick
we're so close
yet so far
here we go i got it i got it here we go
here we go
[Music]
yeah
nailed it that that was fun
for tourists ironically the prison looks
fun
help police someone snipped my clip
it's going to be amazing for when you're
high it's amazing period yeah and i'm
i'm high
i've drank 15 mics hard limited today
here we go
here we go
eating a purpose
all right hey ryan johnson what's up uh
conan's in his office working on
segments right now
what do we do here
oh look if you turn your guy it turns
the guys down there oh yeah look at that
wait so so and an egg comes out
oh geez well you have to get the egg
over here okay
oh you know what if i sniff your clipper
oh yeah it sniffers that
clipper oh so wait you know what here
redo yourself real quick
here come this way
i'm going to make a scoop out of your
head
all right
turn yourself a little left
great good job we need to do that for
you too i think
right
here hold on just try okay
here we go
oh sorry oh oh now we're not now we're
in this [ __ ]
here let's do here let's do that side
you wanna do that side all right
oh or let's do this side i didn't mean
to go over there
wait
trying try going that way
oh
oh i hit the button oh sorry sorry sorry
that's mine
all right you wanna do your way
we suck at this
hey egg producers do not have a
do not hire us to
wait wait wait hey egg producers i don't
know we're watching i guess chickens
yeah
oh look it's little ones of us
oh now we need to get it on the other
one so you need to go hit yours
yeah stay away from it
oh
[ __ ]
wait careful
yes
nailed it
this is exciting well done warm coat
very good pro throw you're right it's
bizarre even for nintendo oh dude wait a
second
whoa now we got to do this one all right
you want to go first with me
sure
oh oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh yeah we got this
[Music]
oh here you do you're huge
that's what she said
about my eggs
they're huge
go lower
yeah go lower that's what she said
about
the egg passing
oh yeah
nailed that one oh
wait i think my thing has to be higher
what hold on redo my thing i think my
thing has to be higher hold on
put your butt in my head poop you're on
your butt there we go all right ready
yep
so creepy
this game is spectacular well played
laura lynn gaming
ready been here since you guys started
still haven't gotten bored well thank
you jay kryptonite yeah
there you go yep yep yep and whoop
what the [ __ ] i think you went too fast
ah
premature egg
whatever
yeah
come on we're we're guys we're in the
same pants which means we already think
alike all right
that's right take it easy
what about if i get a little roll going
you know oops whoops
[Music]
here we go
yeah nice dunk what was that it was a
shitty high five you were like
well i'm focusing we're not done yet was
that where you're doing your focus yes
everyone else stream on sunday uh you're
the chosen kappa i'm sorry i had to go
to a friend's house
uh i went to a friend's house to watch
tombstone it was awesome that's cool
for that moment here but uh we'll do
we'll do a stream tonight
it'll be fun over on aaron blair
twitch channel all right ready
boom sauce
all right here we go here we go
oh
there we go baby
slam it in that's a she said oh god
yes
oh my god oh dude
this is now this
all right i hate this all right let's do
it
ready yeah
oh this is me okay i mean we gotta we
got a good scoop position oh this sucks
by the way
oh this sucks real hard nah nah we got
this do we this is gonna be the tough
part get your guy down here
i'm coming from the other side
oh yeah wait no you have the right idea
wait oh no this sucks wait keep it right
there keep it i'm trying
there it is slam it in yeah
wait what happened oh it broke you did
it too hard i wanted to slam it in how
come i slimmed in every other time it
didn't work what origin is my name
anyway it's belgian
uh it's belgian blurt it's a mess it's
the sound you make when you're dry
heaving blur
that's the pickup line i use on girls is
that your yeah
also by the way i got wait listed on
raya so there you go
what oh the raya is the thing for famous
people oh [ __ ]
you know it's like that dating after
famous people got wait listed didn't get
on well i'm not famous enough or have
enough followers or whatever so gently i
need to gently coast gently gently there
it is oh yeah boom sauce
oh
all right here we go here we go here we
go
it's coming uh can't get on raya
is anyone out there on raya i'm i'm i
want to know what it's like i hear
i heard instead of photos they make you
do like a musical montage
to music so i wanted to use like john a
john grisham audiobook
you know like
like the rainmaker or something as like
my photo montage awful
it's terrible
uh life's a nightmare guys i'm gonna die
alone we all know there we go we all
know it
this would be a great first date
wouldn't it hey come on over let's play
some snipperclippers and then she
immediately like i have to go to the
bathroom and doesn't come back
that's true
have i told the story about the about
the bowling and my friend during the
stream
my friend this is a true story
actually this probably isn't appropriate
for this probably not the thing this
thing yeah yeah okay it's not
appropriate but
whatever you can imagine do i normally
what i normally play when i stream my
own channel uh metro afc tonight we're
going to be playing some resident evil
7. i've been working my way through that
horrifying game
uh it's very scary but uh amazing super
fun
how many sub levels does this level have
uh that was it so that would have been
nope not true retro reboot here we go
sub level
nostalgia loading bleep bloop
[Music]
this game is driving my blood pressure
high slowly i'm gonna have to step out
yeah it's just aaron blair on twitch
thank you buddha
i'll tell that story on my twitch
tonight about how my friend was an
absolute piece of garbage
tuna mandate tuning in tonight for a
terrible oh this is cool look it's got a
crt effect you know what crt effect is
it's like a monitor with scan lines get
your [ __ ]
anyone wants that because it's cool but
it's like pac-man it's you know what on
the on the mini nes you can you can play
it like this so it looks like 80s
yeah i have one of those you do yeah
how'd you get one of those what do you
mean
i mean mom got it for me for christmas
oh mama
look we have to get in i know carrie
sorry
there'll be a stream tonight though
don't worry guys
resident evil stop being scary in five
dude have you played sb canada have you
played the new one it's really good
all right hold on we got to figure we
got to do some cutting here i'm in my
part no you're not at all
let's think about this we want to be
this is me yeah yeah so take that out
hold on
so slice me i'll come back a little all
right there we go all right so we're
good here now wait you need to be the
same but on the other side right uh hold
on
let's look yeah if you go upside down go
upside down
yeah i need to cut that piece out of you
so that means
wait can you
not a math guy
clearly
that might work
yeah
snip away
although how am i going to stand on you
[ __ ] that might work it might work it's
gonna work great
all right get up there
oh come on wait
we're just not lined up right
wait maybe i can yeah there we go
i owe you a chainsaw vagina butler i do
call those things a seahorse seahorse
did you almost see a starfish because
you know a starfish is in the shape of a
star yeah i know
that's why it's called a starfish i'm
not a marine biologist really yeah are
you sick
no i
just just got stuffy just now no i meant
mentally
the answer is yes play a little more
resident evil 7 this weekend everyone is
in for a scary good time it's really fun
it was scary oh scary shut up it's
really scary it sounds scary looks like
the world has made its way i don't know
what that means all right here we go
oh no alejandro why are you depressed
hello all right all right what are we
doing here
seahorse this is a really fun co-op game
beast the far east i would give this i'd
like this game a lot i give it five
stars it's fine this would definitely be
a good first date game by the way yeah i
agree you should do it yeah if i can
ever get a first date well then yeah
the problem is the getting of the date i
don't think i don't have a problem
getting what do you mean no one's
getting a dude who's this little guy
right here not to change the subject
away from what we're talking about he's
cute though
uh oh we gotta get this little guy back
to his little friends yeah all right so
oh my god she's a little guy all right
so wait can you uh cut me cut me
cut me coach
got him cut me again cut me again over
here get out of the freaking way
well we killed him he's dead okay come
over here can you cut me again please
where right here right here yeah
now we can get up here
all right get him over there bro
oh you know what we got to get him on
this side of underneath yeah
oh you know what you have to get him
inside of you
what
sorry
i mean like sexually
no no because see i'm gonna pull the
gate across you know what i'm saying so
you got to get on the other side of me
does that make sense dude no i think you
just got to snip me so i can crawl under
here with him and then you pull the gate
across
snip my top
oh i okay uh snip your top
yeah there we go
is that gonna work yeah that's not gonna
no that's not gonna work there's no way
it's gonna work you're totally wrong cut
me mick
i need to get them on top of me though
there we go come on little guy it's not
meeting people it's talking to people
that's a problem it's all the problem
jungle gymmania
all right yep yep yep now you have to
get out of the way
it's not always the problem with me
oh i'm so close there you go you got him
and i'll move it you can't you can't
move it i'm like i'm gonna get him over
here though all right you get it yeah
get it get
through okay maybe i wait i'm gonna cut
you into the thing come over here i'm
gonna cut you into a bowl
come here put your head over this way
is that a bull all right kind of
kill them sorry my bad my bad
all right you go past me here go go go
go go go go go
oh [ __ ] sorry i punched him in the dick
i'm gonna snip the tip get him inside of
you andy butts exactly
all right all right you got it you got
it you got
hold on can you just please hold on to
your child for one second
turn yourself into a bucket
all right he's got him he's got it he's
bouncy
bumbles bounce oh oh oh oh hold on hold
on hold on hold on hold on hurry alright
do it
jump get him up there get him up there
hold on
yes yeah
oh
that was nerve-wracking let's never be
parents all right
snip the tip
irene says if you ever have a date and
say that to the girl you're playing this
game with at least your neighbor thinks
you have fun my neighbors
i hear a lot of weeping i think from my
apartment
mostly me playing resident evil 7. i do
wonder what they think when i'm
screaming
what i scream which is a lot of
profanity
uh okay we got a little heart here all
right the heart needs to go we got this
thing over here we have to break these
hearts
how do we
oh this is neat
we got to release that heart
what do we have to do here look oh we
got to get the heart over there oh we
got to get the heart over there
this is going really well so far
oh my god this music is making me insane
and i don't hear my dreams
everyone on the stream is like we hate
you we hate this game
there jump and get it in jump and get it
in where are we getting it in right
there right there
i thought the door was closed
oh you know what here get out of the way
maybe it'll
it'll just skate down
oh good good try
god sucks this sucks
youtube's doing great today you got do
we have to break these hearts ah shannon
maybe you're try cutting me into
something i don't know this isn't
working at all
not just like a flat other thing try
cutting me into like a shape
i don't like when they
it's like eagles
hey that's a good shape right there that
you're like a little pac-man
that's a good shape you're such a hail
all right
is anyone still there is this is this
even
look we're doing good let's not get down
on ourselves
look see it's perfect shape
well you know what it's it when we go
close to the thing it closes up so we
have to go far away from it oh when you
stand on the blue
yeah
what is that what is this thing over
here oh look at this oh
dude wait a second game changer
here can you here you get on the thing
this thing
you're i'm trying to push it up let's
try to push it up
there we go can you can you get under me
and push me up higher
that's this isn't working at all in any
way it's just working hold on i'm going
to try to cut the tuck i'm going to cut
your top
god so freaking creepy
there you go can you push that there you
go yep you got it boy
i'm just gonna
keep cutting random pieces oh there you
go yeah yes yes dude great yeah
now what do we how do we get these
stupid hearts up there
hurry i can't hold it forever yes you
can yeah you're not even yeah you what
do you mean you can't hold it you're
just
get under me and push
oh
is that is that the right thing to do
is that's the right thing
don't the heart get away the freaking
giggle in the background sounds like
gage from pet cemetery oh that's a great
reference i think you can
maybe we need to be doing something
differently
oops
sorry dude
i like this look that's okay it is a
good look for you it's like mostly bow
tie
ramp it in oh yeah let's ramp it in
let's ramp it in hold on wait let's all
right let's go back to our old selves
oh to be a shape and just be able to
change you know
all right so i'm gonna make you into a
ramp so come over here right yeah
all right so
wait a second
stay right there
oh sorry
[Music]
okay
all right so i'm gonna go here i'm gonna
try wait let me see if i can make you a
little bit better of a rain come on
okay
now
yeah
i'll get out of the way
i'm going to hit these on there okay
i'm going to send them over the to you
and see if you can
jump up
nope
nope i like the idea though
what about can you make me into a ramp
then we're like a double ramp two
strands yeah a ramp deuce
it's when you take a deuce on a ramp
this is
a terrible ramp
that's a that's the worst ramp i've ever
seen in my life that is the literally
the worst there it's not a good ramp
stop giggling it's so scary there cool
ramp oh dude i'm cool guy ramp
okay so now
god we just sound like we're just
taking this we're trying to poop
we're trying to
just sound like two things
okay check this out check this out bro
bro check me out check me out bro check
in check me out bro check me out
check me out check me out
and jump nope and jump nope and jump
boom yeah wait
now they're making noise earmuffs
we're starting to get that most this is
no longer fun i'm mostly furious at
sniper clips but that's true make hook
and pick it up
you got it you got it
rj just sounds tired of this game by the
way i am so tired of this game
excuse me
oh oh my god dude do not mess with the
heart surgeon over here thank you so i'm
calling myself
okay poke it in poke it in
yes all right now we just got to do a
flip how do we get that one up there oh
we're back to that one
yeah make a little ramp i can stand up
and i'll knock it off here stand on me
here
i'm giving you the ramp i'm giving you
the ramp
hey how's that going how's that going
over there
here let me try let me try i'm thinner
than you yeah
all right
oh that's a good you know what that's a
good boy that's a good there you go
oh no no we got dude don't give up so
easy bro
wait wait wait once you get it
then we're gonna slowly back up so the
door goes away then we're gonna throw it
in
yeah we got it we got it we got it
here we go wait wait we got this we got
this we we got the other two on this one
yeah rj hang in there
it's difficult we got
we got
here we go
here you wind the thing i'm gonna die
because he's not gonna let us we only
have two i know dude we'll get it in
there don't worry
we're gonna get it in
i'm gonna penetrate the tunnel with this
pink thing i don't think with my pink
heart with my pink
i don't think i can get this over you
got it dude you got it you have to come
on bro
i need another she needs hearts i need
another snip hold on
here snip me
i got it man i got i got it i got it
yeah you do yeah you do
no you don't here i need a sniff give me
a snip where do you want where do you
want to snitch here yeah sure
was that a good snap i don't know
no
i need a shorter snip
i need i need a shorter you need a
shorter snip
it's too long you're too long yeah
hold on would you chill
oh my god
all right get over there you got this
reminds you establish animation movies
yeah yeah
who unravel i'll try that lol
scissor sisters that's right
yeah let's both do it at the same time
you got this man oh you're so close
there it is
double trouble
get in there start spinning
yeah
nice
oh god hell yeah
dude bro
nailed it guys i think that's gonna do
it for uh uh this uh this episode of
stream cooking wouldn't have been a more
exciting ending
couldn't have written it any
better
yes we could have absolutely we could
have um
you're physically exhausted from this
game
uh thank you for joining us
we're just playing sniffer clippers
which is a great game uh on the nintendo
switch uh
rj thing i love your switch this is my
first switch switch experience it's fun
though right these are great thank you
for having me this is a lot of these are
awesome thanks uh thank you all for
joining us next week we're gonna have uh
nascar drive around so make sure to come
by and and watch us play some fantastic
racing games and make sure to watch the
show tonight yes who's on the show
tonight i don't know awesome cool
it's gonna be a great show make sure
you'll be good to tune in tonight at 11
on tbs of course if you want to see our
mexico show teamcoco.com mexico mexico
it's amazing keep watching it it's great
i've seen it five times and i lived it
uh thank you guys for joining us we will
see you all next week see you later bye
you